[Music]
given the size of the mcu it was already
obvious that the story of the avengers
would not end after iron man and the
others however many of our heroes are
now retired and new marvel releases like
eternal suggests that even more stories
will take place outside of earth
nevertheless in 2021 new superheroes
have gradually crept in which will
protect the earth together in the future
there's talk of course of the young
avengers what you could guess from tommy
and billy maximoff in one division is
pretty certain at the latest through the
series hawkeye the young avengers are
coming a date has not yet been announced
by disney but a lot is already known
about the cast in addition we can draw
some conclusions about this story based
on the villains introduced so far and
the comics themselves of course here's a
certain risk of spoilers since we refer
to available information from the mcu
and the comics
let's first look at the history of the
young avengers so far the first
appearances of the young superhero squad
were in the comics of 2005 where they
began to replace the superheroes who had
already chucked the hammer in at the
time they were led by nathaniel richards
also known as iron lad even though this
group was quickly disbanded by the old
avengers the young superheroes reformed
under scotland's daughter cassie and
kate bishop these two we've already had
the pleasure of meeting in the mcu
bishop actress haley steinfeld also said
at the press conference for hawkeye that
she's pretty happy to sit here with all
these heroes but this is just the
beginning a lot is possible the
screenwriters have plenty of material
since 2005 the up and coming heroes have
already played a minor or major role in
69 comics
but what can the new heroes do who are
they and in which movie or series do
they play a role we've taken a closer
look for you below
only recently introduced kate bishop who
will follow in the footsteps of clint
bartnik a hawkeye the series with the
same title ran in late 2021 and
surprised many fans and critics although
it was more of a family series and time
for the christmas season there are
enough storylines and action the fact
that clint can now finally retire and
focus on his family is certainly
pleasing to all the fans who've been
with the show since the very beginning
kate has a hard job ahead of her until
she lives up to the big name what we've
already seen however convinces us all
along the line if you haven't watched
the series hawkeye yet you should do so
as soon as possible
america chavez comes from the so-called
utopian parallel a utopian parallel
world which exists outside of space and
time she can travel through the
multiverse and lands on our earth after
the destruction of her universe since
she has supernatural abilities unlike
humans she starts protecting humanity
and joins the young avengers in the mcu
she will appear for the first time in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness which is expected to be released
in the us on may 6th the young heroine
is played by social gomes who was last
seen in the babysitter's club
the two brothers tommy and billy maximov
made the debut in the series one
division and are the children of wanda
and vision in this they have the
superpowers of their mother and their
uncle piedra maximoff aka quicksilver
who gave his life in the fight against
ultron they haven't gotten their
superhero names in the series yet but
the comic readers among you know of
course that billy is wiccan with the
powers of his mother scarlet witch and
tommy speed we certainly don't have to
explain to you where this name is
derived from in the credits of one
division wanda is seen performing a
powerful spell and hearing the voices of
her children surely a sign that they
will still play a role
and the first two and man parts you
quickly fell in love with lily cassie
lang a humor and unwavering loyalty to
her father quickly made her one of the
most popular characters in the films of
course after not being killed by thanos
she aged quite a bit in ant game and is
now teenager in the comics she lives
with her father at the avengers
headquarters where she secretly injects
herself with pym particles without the
knowledge of the others by doing so she
alters her genes and develops
superpowers like her father she can
shrink or grow taller without this suit
though that produces a disney series
about the character can be seen in the
fact that she was recast in the upcoming
quantum mania once again with katherine
newton most of you know her from pokemon
detective pikachu there she plays the
role of lucy stevens
a character that few of you might have
actively noticed is eli bradley known
the comics as patriot this was the
grandson of isaiah bradley who like
captain america was subject to the super
soldier program eli and his grandfather
are already known to us through the
series falcon and the winter soldier in
the comics eli is sought out by iron lad
who wants to assemble a new squad eli
says he received superpowers through a
blood transfusion from his grandfather
however this turns out to be a lie
instead he has injected himself with a
drug mutant growth hormone which is also
supposed to give superhuman strength
whether we will see eli brella again is
not yet known however the creators have
already opened the door for further
appearances in the mcu
with kamila khan aka miss marvel a new
superheroine is coming home to us with a
series in 2022 it's about a young
teenage girl whose great role model is
none other than captain marvel herself
camilo is growing up in a pakistani
family in the middle of new jersey her
parents are strict muslims which makes
it difficult for her to fit in when she
sneaks to a party at night she gets
caught up in the so-called terrigen mist
a cloud that causes inhuman powers in
some people henceforth she possesses a
lasting ability similar to mr fantastic
the heroine is played by iman valani it
is her biggest role so far the fact that
she will meet her great role model has
also been confirmed in the meantime as
she has been given a role in the captain
marvel sequel the marvels in addition to
her solo series
another superhero series is set to fill
the void left by tony stark we are
talking of course about this superhero
iron heart behind the new super suit is
young riri williams a 15 year old
prodigy starting on scholarship at the
mit secretly she builds a suit which is
in no way inferior to that of iron man
the heroine is supposed to make her
first appearance in black panther
wakanda forever so she may have her
roots there in 2023 she will get her own
series on disney plus of course it will
be named iron heart
at this point we still don't know
anything about the plot online however
the fans have settled on two theories
which we will get into in more detail
but as we said these are pure theories
not confirmed facts
kang the conqueror
his story in the loki series has shown
that can go play a huge role in the mcu
after all he's arguably the greatest
time travel villain in the comics he
like iron lad is an incarnation of
nathaniel richards the father of reed
richers who's the leader of the
fantastic four iron lad could therefore
have traveled back in time with the idea
of forming the young avengers and thus
preventing himself from later becoming
kang the conqueror it would also be
conceivable that as to the comics
patriot and iron lad bring the young
avengers into being but nathania
gradually becomes aware of his true
nature and becomes a villain after that
it would be up to the new superheroes to
fight iron lad all around the kang this
will be supported by the fact that kang
has already been introduced and that in
addition to the multiverse time travel
could also play a larger role in the mcu
in addition the cast would already be
almost complete of course the character
of iron lad would have to be worked on a
bit but the producers have already had
freedom in the past as far as the
characters are concerned
thanks to the eternals the celestials
now play a bigger role in the mcu it is
conceivable that a new villain will be
introduced from this part of the comics
and one of the most powerful that has
ever existed in the comics we're talking
of course about the planetary galactus
similar to the birth of celestial he
absorbs the energy of a planet to become
even more powerful destroying it
completely he's also one of the oldest
beings in the universe having existed
before the big bang so it would be
conceivable that he will be introduced
in eternals too and gradually build up
then it would also happen as with our
previous avengers that the heroes of
earth and the universe fight side by
side a slightly bigger sticking point to
this theory galactus would probably be a
bit too strong for our young avengers
but who knows what else the producers
will come up with
see you next time
[Music]
you